but first
hundreds of wisconsin national guard
troops are activated ahead of the
expected verdict in the kyle ritton
house trial next week and as the judge
rules that the jury will be able to now
consider lesser charges there are
reports that he is getting death threats
and one of them reads enjoy your term
judge it's going to be your last if i
ever meet you in person i fully intend
to spit directly into your face
regardless the cost you're disgusting
now rittenhouse's mother is coming to
the judge's defense
judge schroeder is a fair judge he does
not like the nonsense in the courtroom
and anybody that
lives in kenosha or kenosha county knows
that and he is a fair judge and
i have respect for that
all right guys emily i want to come to
you first because i want to talk about
these lesser charges you know this reads
to me like prosecutors feel like they're
not going to get this guy on the murder
charge so they're going to try for
something else is that what you're
reading to
right i think that's a good overarching
takeaway from this and keep in mind that
the more charges that are thrown at the
jury the more explanations the more
complicated it becomes then the more
confused they are and frankly the harder
it is to come to a seamless consensus
decision for kyle rittenhouse and this
is what i want viewers to understand
first of all if prosecutors seek those
lesser convictions then a life sentence
is off the table and what was going back
and forth between the judge and
prosecution and defense are lower
charges on both the initial murder from
intentional homicide down to a lower
degree meaning that yes he feared his
life was in danger but it was an
unreasonable use of force and the second
decrease was in regards to the
endangered the reckless endangerment
homicide and that is essentially or
actually that wasn't the homicide it was
the shooting and that was that there was
no utter disregard for life regarding
the reporter that was standing behind
the victim there so there's a lot to go
into for these juries but i think that
what remains to be seen is how the
prosecution will seek these actual
charges and remember there's a chance
that they might still throw in a
provocation instruction which means that
regardless if we think if the jury
thinks that indeed he feared for his
life and used reasonable force for that
self-defense argument it throws it all
off the table if it was he who provoked
those men that night okay we're going to
see what happens in the next
48 hours here he should come out with
something on monday
sean there has been so uh so many
outside opinions on this case you know
people like lebron james this week got a
lot of heat because he was pretty much
making fun of kyle rittenhouse saying
that he was being fake on the stand when
he was crying cnn's don lemon seems to
think that the judge is being biased
calling him um
saying that he's treating kyle rayton
house as if he's his grandson and then
there's this the media basically
slamming
the judge here watch
i've never seen anything like this
before or a judge yelled quite like this
his behavior is um at the very least
unusual
and um concerning treating kyle
rittenhouse as if he's his grandson
um you know
just just berating the prosecution no
one needs to be berated like that in a
courtroom he has made a series of
decisions each one perhaps may be
individually defensible but in totality
lead to the impression of a biased
racist judge
okay but there are people who've known
this judge for years and they completely
disagree with this meanwhile he's
getting threats sean what's happening
here
so let's take a step back for a moment i
think to you know per emily's analysis
when you look at the facts and you want
as a prosecutor you want to make it as
simple as possible for the jury to
understand so yes uh kyle rittenhouse is
there yes he might maybe he shouldn't
have been there some jurors might think
and he had a gun they might think he
shouldn't have a gun
but when you simply look and say he did
not prompt or instigate anything with
the protesters and when he came into
conflict he actually fled he tried to
get away he ran away until his life was
in danger until he fell and someone
pointed a gun at him did he actually
fire when someone was you know uh
swinging a a skateboard at his neck did
he fire or he was caught behind a
dumpster so i think when you simplify it
uh this is a really easy case of
self-defense but here's my concern aisha
it's that if you have liberals on the
jury as you look at as you listen to
liberals across the country they're not
looking at facts they're just about
emotion and the emotion of this is very
real for them and if you get 12 liberals
on the jury they very well may convict
them but we have to remember it has to
be unanimous so all 12 jurors have to
agree to guilt or to innocence if anyone
disagrees it'll be a hung jury they'll
have to retry it and just one last point
i think this prosecutor was a horrible
prosecutor and and the defense and the
prosecution they don't they're not the
evidence it's the witnesses and the
videotape but both lawyers present
theories of the case to the jury
and it matters how believable you are
and if the jury doesn't like the
prosecution um they are not going to
side with their theory so a whole bunch
of factors in play here yeah and we've
seen that in big cases in the past too
you know joey there is what's happening
inside the courtroom and then there's
the court of public opinion you know
last year
more than a hundred businesses just
destroyed by protests in kenosha people
are nervous the national guard is ready
to go how do you think this ends if kyle
rittenhouse is acquitted of murder
would would getting in trouble for
lesser charges would that matter or do
do you foresee more of what we saw last
year
i think the fact that the the people
that that died in this incident are
white is probably the only saving grace
from riots happening because i think
that race has played a big issue in the
riots and it's been something that
people jump on top of and say look
they're racist and and kind of incite
people's passions that way i think it's
gonna be a lot harder to use that same
line of thought if kyle rittenhouse is
found not guilty you know outside of all
of that i think the one thing people
need to understand is that every state
gets determined it's self-defense laws
in in big part based on precedent and
what the state constitution allows every
state has the opportunity to decide uh
what israe isn't admissible into a court
like this and i think at the end of the
day what people need to need to do
what i'm most worried about is if kyle
rittenhouse is found guilty on say a
provocation clause in this court case
what the judge is trying to do is narrow
this down to the two or three
split seconds that actions happen and
were they were they justified in that
moment what the prosecution is doing is
they're conceding that they probably
were justified in that split second and
that's why they're going to intent and
that's why they're going to provocation
and everything that led up to that
moment what i don't want to happen is
for the people in that in that state to
lose their self-defense rights based on
rights based on case president because
this has become such a big deal and the
jurors may be influenced by outside
media like don lemon or the president of
the united states calling this man a
racist before he ever went on trial i
think he made a lot of stupid decisions
and as a second amendment supporter i
definitely don't want people to go act
the way kyle rittenhouse did leading up
to that moment but everything i've seen
in studying the second amendment
self-defense and every opportunity i've
had the opera i've been able to i see
someone that used a gun in self-defense
justifiably
even if they didn't do uh common sense
things leading up to that and like the
judge said he's not on trial for not
having common sense he's on trial for
whether or not he used self-defense
legally and for every other resident of
that state i hope that self-defense is
withheld are held up in this trial and
sean really
one last point though yeah i will just
so just you know so governor ever said
he's going to call it the national guard
right that's a good thing so we don't
have rioting but what happened in
wisconsin is kenosha was burning for
days and governor evans didn't do
anything else i was talking to the
president and his team
and we're begging governor eva's to send
the national guard and stuff this out if
governor evers had done his job there
would be no riot there would be no case
there would be no death and frankly ever
should be on trial not kyle rittenhouse
sean emily do you think we get a verdict
quickly
yes i do and i think where it's going to
be for one of those lesser charges i
foresee the reckless endangerment the
lower second-degree version and that is
a maximum of 10 years in prison with the
misdemeanor of having that gun which is
nine months but he will serve a lot less
okay